hi everyone welcome to my channel
and in this video we'll talk about amino
acid
catabolism so we are going to get an
overview how protein is broken down to
amino acids
and how these amino acids are broken
down to
nitrogen and how it is excreted
so we know that in our
stomach in our intestine with the help
of several enzymes such as trypsin
chymotrypsine
carboxy peptidase peptine all of these
things
degrade proteins into the simplest form
which is amino acid
and the amino acid is absorbed in the
intestinal epithelial cells
and then it moves into the blood which
is
actually used to make muscle proteins
or other aspects right
but in this video our focus is how
protein breakdown occurs at a molecular
level
so proteins are broken down into amino
acid
that is the basic uh constituent of a
protein
now this amino acid is further broken
down
the amine part of the amino acid
generates ammonia which is further
excreted as
urea whereas the carbon skeleton
is recycled and used in several
biosynthetic pathways such as
tca cycle now in this video we'll look
at
the overview of a amino acid catabolism
so amino acid catabolism the hub of
amino acid catabolism is the liver
so imagine there are four amino acids so
each of these amino acid would donate
their amine group to a substance
which is ultimately glutamate
so it would generate glutamate from
glutamate
ammonia would be generated and alpha
ketoglutarate would be
a side product of it now this ammonia
is extremely harmful and toxic so
ammonia would be converted into a less
harmful
form which is actually urea and urea
is the form which is excreted right
now the process of conversion of several
amino acid to glutamate is known as
transamination
where these amino acids donate their
amine group to glutamate
now from glutamate the process of
generation of ammonia is known as
deamination
and lastly the urea cycle generates
urea from ammonia so this
is the overall workflow of
amino acid catabolism so let's look into
this
process in bit more details so the first
step
is nothing but breaking down of amino
acid
into glutamate or funneling it into
glutamate
and all happens inside the liver
hepatocytes so in the liver hepatocytes
any amino acid
gets converted into a keto acid and this
process is known as transamination
or this is just a amine group transfer
reaction so the amine group is
transferred to what moiety
so the amine group is transferred with
the help of aminotransferases
and the amine group acceptor is nothing
but alpha ketoglutaric acid
it accept the amine group from the amino
acid and itself get converted to
glutamate
so from different kind of amino acid
we get the amine group funneled in form
of
glutamate and the key enzyme here is the
amino transference
the amino transferase plays an important
role in transamination
and the key prosthetic group here is
pyridoxal phosphate
so plp is very important for the
functionality of the
amino transferases now let's talk about
the next step
we have glutamate and the ammon the
amine group
is now in format of the glutamate this
amine group
would be released from the glutamate by
the help of glutamate dehydrogenase
enzyme
this glutamine dehydrogenase enzyme
converts glutamate into a
alpha immunoglutarate intermediate from
which it gets converted to
alpha-ketoglutaric acid
ultimately the ammonia is released but
the problem is this ammonia is highly
toxic
it is highly soluble in the blood so if
it is not excreted in proper
method then it would generate huge
problem and it can even generate
toxicity in the brain
so this ammonia has to be processed in
some way
which is less harmful and it would be
excreted and that excretion format is
known as
urea so ammonia gets converted to urea
by the process of urea cycle so
we'll talk about the urea cycle in bit
more details
so urea cycle takes part in the liver
especially in the liver hepatocyte
inside the liver hepatocyte a portion of
the urea cycle takes place in the
mitochondria and portion takes place in
the cytoplasm
so in the mitochondria we have quite a
lot of ammonia which was derived
from glutamate by by glutamate
dehydrogenase
and the reaction is known as
deamination right now
from ammonia carbohydrate phosphate
is generated with the help of the enzyme
carbomole phosphate
synthetase and in this process as the
name suggests
you need atp to trigger this process and
atp is utilized
to generate carbohydrate phosphate
carbohydrate is
the first product of urea cycle
carbohydrate
combines with another product called
ornithine which is already present in
the liver mitochondria
both of them gets combined and form
citrulline and via several intermediates
such as aspartate arginosuccinate
arginine
it regenerates the ornithine which is
ready
for another round of urea cycle now the
key step
in this process is the conversion of
arginine
to ornithine when argentine gets
converted to ornithin or anything is
regenerated
but at the same time urea is
released so urea is excreted
in this way so we understood
in this video that what is the overview
of amino acid catabolism how does the
process of transamination deamination
and urea cycle work
we have also looked at the enzymes which
are involved in transamination
deamination and urea cycle
and in this video we have not talked
about urea cycle or transamination
process in
details so in other videos we'll talk
about
these processes in way more details but
this was just an
overview to give you a big picture so i
hope you enjoyed this video if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and thank you